he is Basketball Hall of Famer coach of
Kentucky basketball John Calipari here
on the Rich Eisen show how you doing
coach on this elliptical and I ain't
breaking my routine but go ahead talk to
me am I really chatting with you in the
middle of a workout right now yeah I
only have 40 seconds left okay done the
lip button looks like I'm multi-tab this
is impressive so let me ask you this
question how long is the routine that's
now probably has about 30 seconds left
in it I go about four miles a day No
okay that's that's good that's good and
how many do you do per minute six days a
week
fantastic and so the this elliptical is
located in Boise Idaho correct right now
in my room I have any where we stand
make sure I get it in the room so I
don't waste time okay very good
are you through now have we gotten
through the we're giving you the Rich
Eisen shows ovations well done oh my
gosh okay so you're you're watching the
the tournament selection show and you
think what when you hear you got a now
hop a flight to Idaho to take on a team
that just shocked everybody the point
that Notre Dame's bubble popped coach um
well also knowing we got to play on
Thursday I was in my car because we were
traveling back and my phone blew up and
it was bouncing around the seat and the
reason is everybody was like they got
you again they did it to you again it
puts you in a region you know and so at
this point I have not looked at a
bracket I know we have to play Davidson
who by the way is an eighth or ninth
team maybe better they're not a twelfth
see most efficient team in the country
will shoot thirty threes if they make
twenty my young team has had a hell of a
season
mm-hmm but we have to then play on
Thursday so will one day short and that
makes it even tougher
John Calipari here on the Rich Eisen
anybody feel sorry for me no I don't I
don't know I think there are tiny
violins playing but you know I
understand what you're saying I mean I
guess everybody has some form of an
issue and at least I guess you're you're
in the dance and and today it's every
year stuff you know last year North
Carolina used to LA on us in the same
little region to get to a Final Four
mm-hmm why would you do that I mean is
there a reason you would do that I can
remember one year worth oh hi Oh state
North Carolina and us in Newark the year
we won the national title mang the year
we went to the Final Four with the twins
and Julius and James and Willie and Alex
and that crew I mean we're in there with
Louisville and Michigan I mean we are
you look over the years there ain't no
easy path but that makes it even more
rewarding and I tell the kids you know
what throw the hardest thing at us make
it so it seems impossible
I love chasing impossible I still say
before I retire I'd like to have a
season we win all 40 games we've won 38
three different times I'd like to say
let's go to 40 why not that's impossible
you can't do it I'd like to have 12
players right now we have four 12
players play in the NBA all-star game so
half the game as our guys right now we
have four in there let's get it to 12 I
mean but let's do the impossible why not
John Calipari here on the Rich Eisen
show so you do not know who you might
face if should you survive
I know Virginia because everybody talked
about it but I don't know who Virginia's
playing I don't know the rest rest of
the bracket and I don't know any other
bracket I don't know and I don't care
I've got the youngest team in the
history of this tournament we start five
freshmen another freshman off the bench
a sophomore who's 19 years old he might
as well be a freshman because of his age
that's who we are and so my focus is on
how can I keep these guys believing how
can I get them to understand they
deserve this that things are going to
happen in these games
that you look at each other like wow you
can't put your head down you keep
playing and it's never over until that
horn sounds and all you're thinking
about the entire game is how do we win
this you're down six with 30 seconds how
do we win this what do we do to turn
this around and trying to get them in
that mode I mean you know you mentioned
this all access I asked them I look I
don't need an all-access I don't need an
article I mean I've been look I just
need to kind of fade away and I said to
them I said hey guys do you want to do
this it gives people a chance to see
what you guys are
I got great kids I mean these kids and
this has been overwhelming for them and
for all the listeners out there they're
now moving into the the all-access
pieces that were tape when we launched
four in a row so if you want to see
Kentucky when they're losing and what it
looks like it feels like and most people
will like yes I don't want to watch when
you're winning I'd like to see when
you're losing the next couple episodes
are that but this is about getting to
know these players and again we're look
we're up against it but I've had teams
up against it in the past and I just
want to have fun with it and I want them
to have fun John Calipari here on the
Rich Eisen show and by the way today is
the one month anniversary I looked it up
of that of you losing your fourth
consecutive game in a row and I'm
wondering when you're when you're doing
that and you have cameras there now look
kids were 18 I think are used to having
a spotlight on them for many reasons but
since what social media is all about
everybody I think 18 year olds are used
to having an audience for every part of
their lives what what are you thinking
sitting there thinking I've got a bunch
of 18 19 year-olds four-game losing
streak and the March Madness is around
the corner what goes through your mind
coach well first of all the guys tried
to put the mic on me mmm the all-access
and I want to strangle them with the
court but that's one of the things but
the other thing was I've been doing this
30 35 years I've been through just about
everything
we were playing better we just couldn't
put 40 minutes together or the
last two minutes of a Tennessee game an
Auburn game we fall apart well that's
what inexperienced guys do and I kept
saying we're getting better but I knew
this rich we had to win a game we
couldn't go Oh in 12 we were owned four
we had to win a game we had Alabama at
home who at the time was playing out of
their minds and we beat them then we
beat Missouri
then we went on the road and beat
Arkansas and we all of a sudden we're
like we're the team and we go to Florida
on a noon game again inexperienced guys
they don't know noon they think it's
there in Vegas playing three games the
first ones at noon second ones at 4:00
the next ones at 7:00 you know I just
don't feel well it's senior night for
Florida and they kick us and we get beat
every which way but loose before the
tournament and I got to get them back
and you know again I keep saying the
same thing to young people and I've done
this throughout my career
you have to conquer yourself before you
can worry about conquering somebody else
you got to be self evaluating yourself
and you can't listen to people around
you tell you it's everybody else well he
takes him out for nothing and you come
out and all of a sudden you can't miss a
shot or you you can't listen to all that
clutter you have to evaluate and say you
know what there's one way for me to get
better I got to get in the gym and I got
to do what the coaches asking me to do
well how is he asking me to play am I
going to fight this the whole year and
then look like I can't play at all I
mean this was about individuals
conquering themselves one and then the
second thing was you're not gonna do
this by yourself you're not in high
school you can't shoot all the balls
there are other players here you have to
create a good shot so they create good
shots for you no no you got to defend
you can't you shoot but don't you wish
at some point you have more experienced
team players that you don't have to
worry about that that they know that
stuff that I coached at UMass that
four-year guys people forget I'm old now
but I used to have those young guys and
yeah I love to coach guys for four years
but not at the expense of Keith holding
a kid back I mean we got we
thirty guys in the NBA they make over a
billion dollars right now a billion and
I was in those homes I was with those
families I knew their dreams and
aspirations you're talking about people
with dignity and hope and yeah I want
their kids to move on but would I rather
have them for four years yeah rich
here's what I tell them when they leave
if you want to do what's right for you
and your family put your name in their
draft now if you want to do what's right
for me and my family why don't you stay
all four years
mm-hmm but it all comes down to it coach
it's always fun watching you out there
on the sidelines and and and against
Davidson and five twelve matchup it'll
be something that the whole country's
gonna be watching right right around
dinnertime out there in Boise in the
last minute in the last minute I have
with you coach is this your first ever
trip to the state of Idaho
no I've been to Twin Falls okay to
College of Southern Idaho which is an
unbelievably beautiful manicured campus
as a matter of fact we drove from there
to jackpot Nevada you never even heard
of jackpot Nevada so I thought the
places you've never bet they had sawdust
on the floors oh yeah they did okay
that's fantastic well I'm watching this
stuff it's it's great a coach really
appreciate you joining and I'm glad that
you got that workout in thank you take
care that's coach John Calipari the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience